Salut à tous, j'espère que vous ne vous êtes pas fait de nœuds au cerveau avec l'énigme d'hier.
Vous savez, tous les jours une énigme pendant 32 jours
et surtout je donne d'abord la réponse de l'énigme de la veille avant de donner la nouvelle.
La réponse de l'énigme de la veille, c'est sûrement une des énigmes les plus compliquées que je connaisse.
Il faut créer un paradoxe dans le paradoxe.
Donc la question que vous allez poser
peu importe qui vous choisissez puisque de toute manière elles ne sont pas identifiables.
Oh ! Avant que je continue, j'espère que vous avez regardé l'énigme, parce que là je donne la solution.
Donc peu importe lequel des deux auquel vous allez vous adresser, peu importe la porte.
Puisque de toute manière, rien n'est identifiable et tout se ressemble.
La question que vous allez poser c'est:
"Si je demande à ton collègue quel est la porte du paradis, il me désignera laquelle ?"
Et là vous vous dites, vous avez raison, jesais pas si c'est celui qui ment ou qui dit la vérité qui va me répondre.
Mais justement, ce qui est malin c'est que la porte que va vous désigner la personne à qui vous posez la question sera toujours la porte de l'enfer.
Pourquoi ? Parce que vous avez intégré les deux dans la manière de répondre.
En faisant ça, vous intégrez forcément le mensonge dans la réponse.
Puisque si la personne à qui vous vous adressez est la personne qui ment, le diable...
alors il devrait vous montrer la porte du paradis puisque Dieu montrerait le paradis
mais comme c'est un menteur il va inverser les réponses et va montrer l'enfer.
Mais si c'est Dieu à qui vous vous adressez, il va dire la vérité
et vous montrer la porte que désignerait le diable, c'est-à-dire la porte de l'enfer.
Donc en posant cette question, vous saurez quelle porte est l'enfer et donc par déduction quelle porte est le paradis.
C'est hyper tordu, mais par contre, 100% logique et 100% difficile aussi !
C'est pour ça que l'énigme d'aujourd'hui sera plus simple.
Énigme numéro 21 pour la Team Mentalo !
J'ai pris un petit papier parce qu'il faut qu'elle soit très précise.
Imaginons qu'on ait fait un concours d'énigmes
que depuis le début de cette série spéciale été, on ait fait un concours d'énigme.
Et que pour ce concours 5 personnes jouaient.
Julie, Naïs, David, Thomas et Albert.
Et que j'ai pu tirer les conclusions suivantes, à savoir:
Thomas, fut ni premier ni dernier.
Julie a résolu plus d'énigmes que Naïs.
David a résolu plus d'énigmes que Thomas.
Thomas a résolu plus d'énigmes qu'Albert, mais moins que Julie.
Nais a résolu plus d'énigmes que David.
Question: Qui a résolu le moins d'énigmes ?
Je vous le refais rapidement:
Thomas ne fut ni premier ni dernier.
Julie a eut plus de points que Naïs.
David a fait plus que Thomas.
Thomas a fait plus qu'Albert mais moins que Julie
et Naïs a fait plus que David.
C'est tout à fait possible de trouver la réponse.
C'est de la logique pure et dure.
Dès que vous avez trouvé, dites "J'ai trouvé !" dans les commentaires
et laissez un pouce en l'air pour qu'on voit le nombre de personnes qui ont réussi à résoudre l'énigme.
Profitez encore du soleil qui reste pendant quelques jours.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir.
Parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an !
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17h.
Ciao !